I know that the phrase Sentinel chickens
does sound a bit ridiculous these
chickens here in Griffith in rural
Australia are not keeping watch for
anything they're not on guard they are
just chickens but they are helping keep
folks in this area of New South Wales
safe from some nasty diseases diseases
like Murray Valley Encephalitis mve it
infects animals including humans and
it's carried by mosquitoes it has no
vaccine no cure most people who get it
will suffer fever and nausea but about
one in a thousand will get seriously ill
with a Chance of life-changing brain
injuries or death if that virus is
starting to flare up in the animal
population around here mosquito
transmission means it can easily spread
to humans so it'll be really useful for
the local Health Department to have an
early warning system we have eight
flocks at the moment and there are 15
Birds per flock they are usually between
9 and 14 weeks old when we get them at
the start of the season they are fed
watered and they lay eggs and that's an
additional bonus for the person who's
looking after our Coop they get to keep
the eggs ideally the researchers would
track levels of the virus in wild
animals and birds that's where it
thrives but that plan involves catching
and testing wild animals not practical
so instead chickens they don't get sick
from mve or other diseases like it and
they can't pass it on either but if they
get infected their immune system still
fights it still creates antibodies the
technical term is zero conversion and
these chickens are outside every hour of
every day and the mosquitoes will bite
them a lot we take a small amount of
blood from each chicken Wiggly they
collect the chickens and then we do a
bleeding process where they take a small
amount of blood via a Lancet from under
the wing collected on a small blotting
strip it's just a very small pin prick
chickens have a leg ban on so that we
know very specifically what bird and
what sample and we can match them up and
that goes off to our labs in Sydney
where they do a number of tests for a
whole range of mosquito-borne viruses
the mosquito levels are important as
well but it's not enough just to track
mosquitoes it's important that we
monitor a reservoir that can give us a
better indication quicker the chickens
give us a pretty early warning within a
couple of weeks if we saw Zero
conversions in our flocks we would ramp
up to local media to get that message
out use a repellent not be outside of
Dawn and dust and wear light loose
fitting clothing camping grips fishing
groups those people that are visiting
areas get the message as well we will
provide information to local GPS so that
they will be looking for symptoms and
there are other flocks in other
countries I'm sure as part of our
surveillance program of course once the
chicken is tested positive its work is
done it will always have those
antibodies it will always test positive
so at that point it is retired and I'm
assured that's not a euphemism and
testing continues on the rest of the
flock I was a bit worried about animal
safety and cruelty hip do you mind the
chickens are well cared for they're just
having a blood sample taken occasionally
in a world with factory farming and
fried chicken shops this does seem
fairly low down on the scale of things
Humanity does to chickens we really have
no other way of knowing what virus might
be around in the area and they do save
lives
never work with animals
this is not food these are my fingers